The joe rogan experience.
That reminds me of the
first time I bought drugs.
The first time I ever bought drugs.
Tell me what you remember.
Do remember the first time you ever
[inaudible] told me that you had a story?
I met the first time about drugs.
I was in high school and I went to a
small high school so I was trying to be
like not make a thing to
ask about it at first.
You know,
cause you don't want it to get
around and like be a cause.
So you were curious.
Yeah,
I wanted to try stuff but I didn't know
who to ask because if you ask like at a
small school you're like
it could blow up real fast.
That's how guys would traveled.
So my friend Steve had just transferred
from like the big high school,
like from a high school
with like 5,000 kids.
And so it was like a weekend.
I was like,
let's get a sack.
And I think we had just seen
menace to society and we were like,
it was up,
but we were trying to totally
be like hardcore guys.
I'm like pulling the hat
to the side and be like,
did you wear your hat to the side?
No,
but I think,
uh,
you know a lot of like throwing
swag into shit and being like,
hey,
it was good a sac.
You get your blackness on.
Definitely feel it.
14 like what's up dude?
This shit.
I got your back making shit up.
Little too white,
right?
Yeah.
And so comfortable with your existence.
Totally.
And then,
uh,
he's like,
I'll hook,
I know the guy.
So this is like a Saturday night.
This like long green,
like old school seventies
Cadillac pulls up and,
and like,
he's like,
that's the dude and this
guy rolls the window down.
He's like,
Yo,
get in the back.
And I was like,
all right,
cool.
We get in the back if the thinking
like that's where it goes down.
And uh,
Steve is like,
Yo,
this is white Pete.
And I was like,
what's up White Pete?
Like he was called White Pete cause they
needed to give him a distinction for
his name because he was the only
white guy that ran with his crew.
Right.
And he was like,
we didn't have driver's licenses.
So he was like,
exactly what we at that moment when
we want it to be in a couple of years.
Like he had like the whole unit,
like the oversized white tea and like,
you know,
gold chain.
Yeah.
And fucking like fate.
And he was like,
what's up?
I'm white people.
He talked like snoop Dogg almost.
Oh right.
And so we were like,
all right,
I thought he was like,
so we're going to go get it now.
I was like,
go get what?
Like I thought we were
just doing this in the car.
I wouldn't go get that sac man.
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
So we start driving,
we go 30 minutes in a car,
we go to the next town over,
which is Fort Pierce,
which is definitely a shittier place,
right.
So we're driving through Fort Pierce and
we go from a main street to like single
lane highways.
You know,
in Florida there's like,
oh yeah.
I said,
we're on a busy,
and then we go to a single lane
that has like canals on each side.
Ooh.
Yeah.
And we're driving.
And then we go from that to a dirt road
and then the dirt road off of that dirt
road that we're driving down with.
Like this is some forensic files.
Shit.
Like we're going to end up on,
there's a lot of woods.
Yeah,
a lot of brush,
uh,
groves,
that kind of shit.
I was like,
fuck man.
And at this point,
like I'm thinking about like
menace to society and they're like,
I want to be in that right now.
But in feeling like,
ah,
feeling really white,
my like really scared and so,
and now it's night and it,
you know,
it's like,
because we,
it,
he came over in the evening already,
so it was pitch black outside and we're
on a dirt road off of a dirt road.
Like you can scream,
there's nobody gonna hear Shit.
And on the dirt road gravel path,
I see a light and the
light is from a trailer.
So we pull up to the trailer
and we get out and it's me,
Steve and white Pete.
And we knock on the door,
that trailer and this dude opens the door
and he has his black guy that has like
six dreadlocks,
like you know,
each dreadlock is like a size of like a
king size snicker bar and he's got six
snicker bars coming out
of his hair and wipe.
He's like,
what's up Pat Pat?
And he's like,
what's up White Pete?
And they give each other,
how can,
I was like,
oh fuck.
Like no,
this really is like totally
menace to society shit.
Right?
But I'm told try.
So trying to be cool about it.
Like,
so trying to be cool about it.
And then uh,
he's like these white boys
looking for a sack and he's like,
yeah,
we could do that.
So we go on.
So the mind you,
we're looking for $20 and we like,
we drove.
And how long has it taken?
This is from his point.
It's like we're already 30
miles southwest of the city.
We started,
would you just say like
never mind after 10 miles
white peach of solid to you,
why does he have to take you
on the trip to the guy's house?
I would,
these are all questions I have,
but don't have the balls to ask.
Like I,
I'm in my mind,
I'm like,
ah,
like I'm 14,
15 and I'm not saying shit to this dude.
I'm cool.
What's up?
He's get a sack full time.
So we go into his trailer and he's like,
all right,
we're going to get to do that sec.
Uh,
we back in 10 minutes.
I was like,
who would be back in 10 minutes?
He's like,
we will be you stay
here and watch my place.
And I was like,
what?
Like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Is what I'm thinking?
But then I just go like,
yeah,
cool.
Totally.
You're in his trailer.
And he's like,
watch it for me.
And I'm like,
oh no.
Like I'm feeling like that,
like real fear.
But I go,
yeah,
no problem man.
I watched people's houses all the time,
like it totally fucking terrified.
And then he goes like the,
you walk in the trailer,
you're in the living room because
that's the way it trained leaders.
Right.
You walk into it,
it was a bedroom to the right.
He's like waiting here on the bed.
He's like,
it was a 45 and a 12 gauge and he goes,
anybody comes into my,
in my house,
you shoot him.
And I was like,
right.
And then he was like a for my Mama,
my mama comes home,
don't shoot her.
And I was like,
got it and accept.
I kept trying to be cool about it.
I was like,
yeah,
like that's what's up.
I know,
I know what you're saying,
man.
Go get that sac.
Totally like trying to be like,
he was like,
all right.
They walk out,
they leave me in his trailer with two
guns and a fucking message to not to shoot
everybody but his mother and I just
sit there and watch the MTV video music
awards and the whole time,
like every show that comes,
I just,
I'm rocking.
I'm actually hoping that it's an intruder
versus his mom because I feel like if
it's his mom,
she accidentally shoot her or I or how
is she going to react to my explanation.
Pep had just told me to wait here.
Oh,
he's getting some weed for me,
but I'm,
that's what I'm supposed
to shoot everybody,
but you
are you cool with that?
And she's like,
Oh yeah,
it happens all it like how are
you going to react to this?
So I fuck,
I mean I'm having a panic attack.
We finally,
they come back,
we get back in with a white Pete.
He drives us back and I'm sitting there,
I'm like,
what the fuck dude,
that was the worst shit ever.
Like I'm fucking terrified.
He was like,
yeah,
him and Pat,
Pat,
pat became like best friends.
So they became like super close.
Like that was like his guy
would go to and I'd be like,
no dude,
I don't want to hang
out with half ad at all.
And like six months later
when Steve got his license,
we went and he was like,
you want to get some weed today?
I was like,
yeah,
yeah.
So where we go,
we go to Fort Pierce,
pull it to pat Pat's and I'm like,
God damn it.
And like she remembered how to get there.
He did.
Steve had started going
there all the time.
Oh my God.
We pulled up to his trailer this time
he gets out now this time I'm like,
well they're friends.
This is probably gonna
be a much quicker thing.
He comes out,
he jumps in the back and he's like,
all right,
let's roll.
And I was like,
ah,
no,
like fucking look for a sack again.
Like I thought you just have this.
So this time we went to this,
but these are things [inaudible] scared
the shit out of me the first time.
But that second time he saved our life
actually because we went from his trailer
the second time where
he jumped in the back,
went to Avenue d,
which is the fucking shitty
street in Fort Pierce.
Like if you're going to like every city,
you know you have like,
I dunno,
whatever city you're in
there like that's ever seen.
If you've been to the street where you
see open drug dealing where there's not
even some type of facade Angeles,
right,
but you've been down a
street where there's like,
there's no pretense about it.
There's just like Los Angeles.
What's,
which part of the film and fear factor?
We were actually filming the playboy
playmate addition of fear factor downtown
area.
Yeah.
We were watching people sell drugs,
smoked crack right there.
We were in a crane and we're like,
I go look,
they're smoking crack.
And the girl's like,
oh my God,
they are smoking crack and
like this is ridiculous.
No one's protecting us.
We're up here on a crane.
That was exactly like this where we pulled
up in in Steve's car and the windows
come down and we just get surrounded.
Like the car got surrounded by six guys
and they reached in their jackets and
they go at this one guy who was,
y'all look familiar and
this other guy goes,
yeah,
y'all are real familiar.
Y'All ever been here before?
And that when you,
when somebody says that you look familiar,
have you been here before?
How would you answer that?
I just say,
nope.
Nope.
All right.
And exactly at that moment I go,
no.
And Steve at the exact same it goes,
Yup.
Yeah
man.
And then they're like,
see,
I told you man,
y'all look like them.
White Boys.
They've been snatching bags around here.
I was like,
Oh fuck.
Like you look like the white boys
that haven't taken bags from guys.
I'm like,
no,
dude,
that's not us.
It seems like,
but we have been here before.
I'm like,
will you shut the fuck up?
Pat?
Pat is in the back of like,
hold on.
He gets out and like walks up,
talks to all of them.
Like,
uh,
you know,
like he's the ambassador,
right?
And like,
I don't know what the fuck you're like,
I own these guys there with me.
He's like,
fucking,
and they totally let us go.
Yeah.
But if without,
without him we would've been fucked.
What's that noise?
What is that noise?
That's not mine.
That's me.
Pat,
pat.
Pat.
Pat is still,
I don't know where it happened to pat.
Pat.
And why Pete,
who knows what happened?
Good things.
Probably not good things,
man.
You said Facebook,
um,
can you fix book pap Pap Pap?
That would be the next person that
makes up a fake Twitter account.
That's a real fee.
That was,
I had real fear.
Oh yeah.
You're like,
for good fucking reason.
Oh.
Like when you feel your
stomach drop and you're like,
what's going to happen right now?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That's terrible shit,
man.
Okay.